Hey YouTubers, this is Charlie.
This is gonna be my Legends of Tomorrow finale video
Just be careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet..
We'll be talking a little bit about Season 2,
they teased some really awesome things. So just careful for spoilers, here we go!
So much awesome  stuff happened at the end and in light of what happened today,
with the upfront Supergirl coming to The CW,
instead of doing my normal Top 10, I'm gonna talk about easter eggs,
and then I'm gonna talk about what is happening after this.
Because they've already confirmed a couple of big things
like Hawkman and Hawkgirl are kinda leaving the series.
They are not gonna be series regulars so they might have a cameo next season
But they're not gonna be main characters.
That's why they're casting a bunch of new people and we saw Hour Man from the Justice Society at the end
So let's talk about Justice Society for a second
Holy Crap! The minute I heard that, I was like OhmaiGaaawd
I just posted a big crossover trailer for the big 4-night crossover they were teasing for next year
I joked about them  doing Justice Society,
like yeah, I'm gonna make a billion dollars someday. They're gonna do Justice Society
because they have four big people and they have a Supergirl now.
So I guess we shouldn't be surprised that Legends of Tomorrow is going full Justice Society
but just because they said Justice Society in the finale, it doesn't mean we're automatically gonna jump to that
and we're gonna have like a Justice Society TV show.
Legends of Tomorrow Season 2 still has the time ship,  they still have the Waverider; so they'll be travelling in time
They've gained Hourman as a series regular, like he's gonna be with them in most of the episodes
Then they're casting a couple of other characters to replace Hawkman and Hawkgirl
and presumably whoever the big villain is gonna be, who they haven't announced yet.
There's a whole of Hawkman comic book history we've got to talk about in a second
but I just wanna talk about Justice Society stuff first.
The interesting thing about this is that when Teddy Sears, the guy who's playing Zoom on the Flash right now, said that whn he was cast,
he was cast as Jay Garrick. He didn't know anything about becoming Zoom.
But because he didn't know a lot about Jay Garrick,
Andrew Kreisberg, who was the show runner on The Flash, gave him Geoff Johns's Justice Society run
to learn about Jay Garrick.Now, technically it's JSA.
Fun Fact: JSA was Geoff Johns's first major title at DC Comics.
He started writing on it during 2000 on Issue no. 6. David Goyer, who's involved with a lot of other comic book,
TV shows, he wrote on comic books for a long time.
David Goyer needed help writing the title, so he invited Geoff Johns to start writing it with him,
Eventually, David Goyer left to work on more movie and TV stuff. So Geoff Johns took over the title
and continued to write it for a long time. So JSA was like Geoff Johns' first major big comic book
that he wrote in DC. But anyway, if you're looking for a deep cut on Justice Society going into S2 of LoT,
you wanna learn about those characters, just read Geoff Johns' run on the title.
But let's talk about hourman.
You may not be super-familiar with him.
He's a big part of that Geoff Johns Justice Society run
but just like a lot of comic book characters, there are a number of different versions of Hourman.
People have taken the mantle, just like The Flash:
Jay Garrick to Barry Allen to Wally West.
There are three different versions of the character,
There's Rex Tyler, that's who we actually met on Legends of Tomorrow. We met the first HourMan.
The second HourMan's called Rick Tyler, then there's Matthew Tyler.
He debuted way back in 1940. SO he's old school Justice Society.
And the title that he actually first debuted in is called Adventure Comics.
Geoff Johns later revived that title in 2009.
So we're on the Geoff John's infinite loop here. This is so funny how deep Geoff Johns is embedded in DCComics
No surprise that he is now in charge of all their films.
What about his powers, though?
Hourman. So he takes this pill called Miraclo and gives him a bunch of different abilities
but only for an hour at a time. So the pill, lasts for an hour.
But in the comics, he's not a meta human. He takes the pills and he gets enhanced strength, enhanced durability, speed
He turns into like a smaller version of Superman
for an hour at a time.
What a coincidence then that an episode of Legends of Tomorrow lasts for about an hour!
Technically, it's 42 minutes becauseof ads, but you get the idea.
When he's all juiced up on the pills, they affectionately call it power hour. So, you can make as many jokes about it as you want.
The twist is that he gets addicted to the pills and becomes very debilitating.
So we might see a version of that on the TV show. I don't know if they're gonna do the pills or they'll just call him a meta human
So just a reminder that this is Rex Tyler, he is the first version of the character.
He's the one that created the drug to give him the powers.
So you can kinda see how he would work on a crossover with The Flash
Caitlin made V-9. So there are a lot of ways to cross Legends of Tomorrow with the other shows
But no idea how thy're going to address the idea of Justice Society beyond this TV show
So on Arrow, on Flash, on Supergirl, they might not refer to it at least right away.
Maybe only during the 4 night crossover event
which will probably end up happening this Fall.
But if you didn't see my video earlier this week,
I did my Legends of Tomorrow from last week during a Batman video ealier
and I explained what's going on with Cap'n Cold. We saw a version of him in the episode
from earlier in the timelinebut he's still dead in present day
What ended up happening is behind the scenes, Wentworth Miller, the actor signed an overall contract
with Warner Bros Television to go on all of the TV series as a regular.
So he's gonna pop upon all 4 DC Comics TV shows. Now that's all they've said. They haven't explained how that's gonna happen
because the most current version of him is still dead.
He died in the future. So we'll see how they explain that, but Captain Cold will still be on all of the TV series
next season. Firestorm powers, though! We finally saw him use his transmutation powers
They'll probably play with that next season. It involves a lot of special effects
That's kinda expensive. So don't expect them to do it all the time.
Like have you ever wondered, how come they just don't form Firestorm and beat the shit out of
you know, whichever villain they were fighting each week. It's because it's really expensive to do special effects like that.
And I almost forgot, one more big Justice Society easter egg:
I've been talking about this for forever, like for the last 4-5 videos on Arrow
But Mark Guggenheim wrote the last big Justice Society arc before the New52 reboot.
It was called, like when the entire run they collected in a tray paperback,
was called Monument Point, which you'll find familiar if you've been watching Arrow this season
some of you may have not, but just watch my Arrow videos. I'll totally explain what's going on with that
It just that he posted this picture, like this is very appropriate to post now because
we're doing Justice Society. We were kinda doing this storyline during Arrow this season..
You get the idea.. it's a lot of fun.
But I promise to talk a little bit about Hawkman's history in the comics.
It is completely confusing.
It's completely ridiculous.
So if you're confused about Hawkman and Hawkgirl's back story, do not be surprised.
Everybody's confused about it.
Nightmare level continuity problems.
So they started in the Golden Age with Prince Khufu (Carter Hall). That's the one that we met here.
That's the one they're doing on the TV show.
During the silver age, he was called Cater Hall. It's still pronounce the same, but it's spelled differently.
In this version of his backstory, he was from the planet Thanagar
where everybody looked like Hawkman. Like, imagine a world full of people that look like Hawkman
That's how they explained it on the TV show.
Thanagarian technology.. sent to Earth in the form of meteors.
So Thanagar exists in this universe. It sounds like they're not really gonna address that in Season 2
Then, during the big zero hour event, they merged all those backstories
and you got one version of Carter Hall.
He's from Earth, he's not the Thanagarian. They went with the Egyptian origin story
Narrating the process, is Waverider here for which their timeship on the TV show is named.
It's called the Waverider, after the Waverrider character in the comic
So you see there's easter eggs all over the place
Don't you feel like you have a Ph.D in comic book easter eggs now
but already you can understand how confusing that is and how they tried to include easter eggsfor that on the TV show
Like their blood activates the Thanagarian technology, so there's some Thanagar in there,
there's some Prince Khufu Egyptian origin story; Golden Age, Silver Age coming together..
They kinda do that with the TV shows because comic books get really messy with continuity
if you go back far enough.
Overall, the episode was pretty good. I did think they stuck the landing and had that amazing twist
So, it was a great finale.
But the series, as a whole, was kinda inconsistent
It took them a little while to figure it out
I think it required them getting access to some special characters,
getting access to Justice Society things.. So all that stuff, behind the scenes
as well as them having to rush the series out just kinda contributed to some of the the early problems
that they had with the stories and now that this year they know going into next year
they already have a Season 2, they can start working on it.
Now they'll have a lot better time to work on the big stories
and that's really the important part.
Getting a really awesome story
the production stuff, they can actually do pretty easily because they have The Flash, Arrow and Supergirl
So from a production stand point, they're a well oiled machine
It just takes time to do really awesome stories
So now that they have that time, I think Season 2 is gonna be pretty amazing
So what does this mean, though, for next week's finales of Flash and Arrow
Are we gonna see any kind of crossover... I feel like the big Justice Society twist on Legends
makes me really crank up my expectations for the finales of The Flash
which I'm, you know, expecting Jay Grarrick to appear on
The real Jay Garrick, and then on Arrow..
I'm a little more in the dark on Arrow stuff just to make more Dahrk puns ;)
Make as many Damien Dahrk puns as you want
The dahrkness.. Take a drink every time someone says darkness on Arrow
But the tagline says Oliver's gonna get help from a very surprise force
Now that could be a person, that could be some magical thing
Just some BIG twist  that I'm expecting now
So lemme know in the comments: What do you think this finale and Justice Society for season 2
means for next week's finales of Flash and arrow?
Now they'll largely have their own plotlines to wrap up
but when they do something THIS big on one of the shows, it usually means something big on the other 2 shows as well
even if they're not completely related.
So what's gonna happen is, is they dropped the teaser for the new Star Trek TV series
I meant to do that now but because of Justice Society, I had to make this video now.
It's too big a deal to not talk about. So that'll be my next video
Some new Game of Thrones posting tomorrow too.
There's any other crazy stuff that they've released, any other news  about next season on Flash, Arrow, Legends
I'll totally do a video for that too.
This is really like the best possible thing that could've happened for the TV series
I'm so excited they're finally doing Justice Society.
While you guys wait for my next video to post,
you can click here for the big crossover, the big 4 night crossover trailer I just posted
And you can click here for this week's episode of The Flash
Thank you so much for watching, everybody!
Let's high five! I'll see you guys tonight!
~Leave a like for JSA ;)~